es mi primera vez exponiendo
en un evento tan importante como lo es
este de c's estoy muy orgulloso de que
me han tomado en cuenta y yo vengo a
hablar del hambre el hambre resiliente
yo he emprendido mi negocio desde hace
alrededor de horas así que lo considero
emprender desde hace ocho años que la
vida me dio la oportunidad de trabajar
de aprender
tengo la experiencia de hijo pero estoy
nervioso
gracias gracias la ciudad
la intención de compartir mi vida con
las personas es darles a entender que se
puede ser emprendedor que se puede tener
un negocio que no necesitas de dinero
yo hice un resumen
para mí los cinco puntos importantes es
primeramente tener tu sueño al momento
de que tú tienes tu sueño elaborar su
proyecto tienes tu idea te imaginas qué
es lo que vas a hacer qué quieres hacer
pero mucha juventud la raza de hoy en
día se frena y ahí es donde entran los
temores y pongo esta flechita porque
cuando tú vas a emprender y dices quiero
hacer un negocio quiero hacer esto y
mira como para que lo voy a echar ganas
a emprender algo no pero entra en tu
cabeza todo el tema de decir es que debo
es que tengo una mensualidad de un carro
es que de una casa es que debo algo pero
al final son puros temores que no te
dejan brincar más allá de tus sueños yo
le llamo hambre porque por qué
tú necesitas
esa parte de hambre de necesidad cuando
yo empecé mi negocio cuando yo emprendí
a mi empresa
yo estaba recién divorciado tenía que
mantener a los hijos tenían que pagar
colegios de mis hijos no tenía un solo
peso más sin embargo me pudo más el
hambre me pudo más quitarme esa
comodidad de decir ya no quiero estar
dependiendo de un horario no quiero
estar dependiendo de algo económico que
me vayan a pagar
emprendí
hubo muchas carencias no existen no hay
una excusa que te diga no puedo
emprender no puedo hacer un negocio todo
se puede hoy en día una parte
fundamental que a mí me ha ayudado en
las relaciones
tienes que relacionarte con mucha gente
hablar conocer para que para que esa
parte de relacionarte te va a dar te va
a dar un empuje a conocer más personas
te va dar un empuje a platicar a
platicar tus ideas uno nunca sabe con
qué personas te vas a topar que puede
impulsar más allá tu negocio
muy algo muy importante que debe de uno
si tener siempre es escuchar en redes
sociales varias personas en este caso a
mí me ha ayudado mucho leer cuando dices
que no tengo estudios es que no sé cómo
hacer un negocio compadre mente está el
internet cabrón el chingo de información
que uno puede resumir mucha información
que puedes ver no ocupas una universidad
no ocupas algo para estudiar y que te
digan oye pues voy a emprender algo no
en mi caso muy particular yo seguí a una
persona en redes sociales
y platicaba con mi hermana con mi esposa
y esta persona hoy espera es que él no
ojalá las cosas que él te dice no
funcionan pues bueno tomen lo mejor de
cada persona que está en el mundo tomen
lo que les guste lo que les caiga les
platico un poquito de mi inicio esto fue
mi inicio esto esto fue este era mi
taller la casa de mis papás del segundo
nivel mis papás y soy afortunado de
venir de una familia humilde afortunado
de venir de una familia donde carecemos
pobreza una anécdota muy importante fue
cuando nosotros hay una anécdota que
comparto con mucho orgullo tan así era
nuestra carencia que mi madre en el
patio de su casa tenía una tenía una
pileta donde ahí va rias las cosas y ahí
mamá de repente si vos sentado dos
centavos
una vez una anécdota muy muy marcada que
nos deja la vida está mi hermana conmigo
y
no teníamos para comer
mamá barría toda la suciedad de la casa
y en esa pileta echaba las cosas un día
no teníamos para comer ni tortillas y
recuerdo que me decía mi hermano hoy es
fíjate en la pileta ahí debe haber
sentados era una pileta mucosa nosotros
metíamos la mano para sacar un centavo
dos centavos íbamos a la tortillería esa
esa anécdota de esa vez fue algo que me
marcó a mí bastante la vida y que yo
dije un día no vuelve a pasarme esto en
la vida es a esa parte hoy en día a eso
le llamo hambre tienes que tener
muchísima hambre para poder salir
adelante para poder crecer no existe una
limitante hay personas que tienen vida
gracias a dios buena que tienen padres
que los apoyen el camino es más fácil
así es más fácil brincar más fácil
seguir no es una limitante hoy en día
orgulloso de tener una empresa
establecida no mundial pero nacional
dándole servicio a clientes muy
importantes como lo es ternium cuprum
continental guía y dices tú en qué
momento aunque momento llegas a que te
reconozca no soy una persona con un
nivel de estudios mínimo una persona que
me ves la calle no das un peso no pero
esa parte de la esencia que tenemos y
que debemos de tener siempre es la
humildad la humildad que nos va a ser
grande es la humildad de saludar al que
barre la humildad de saludar al
directivo la humildad de saludar a las
personas todos todos el eslabón más
importante siempre lo he dicho yo para
nosotros los emprendedores y tienen que
tenerlo bien clavado en la mente de los
empleados no son empleados somos familia
en mi empresa no somos una más nosotros
somos una familia uno tiene que tener
esa humildad de ver ver a tu equipo de
trabajo así
partes de eso
lo que te viene a dar un poco más el
resto recalcando el tema de las
relaciones
es extraño para mí porque si ustedes
platican conmigo a solas soy un peligro
que no se cae y tiene muchas ideas y
siempre he sido me han dicho unas
amistades que inspiró a el crecimiento
las personas que me conocen saben saben
cómo he logrado esto
esto para mí es nuevo espero llegar a
oídos de alguien espero que la juventud
los chavos que el mínimo negocio que
quieran emprender agarren un poquito de
esto hay una enseñanza que que me dejó a
mí un maestro
qué voy a hacer cómo lo voy a hacer y
cómo lo mejor
eso me ha servido en mi vida diaria
le soy tan agradecido el
porqué porque hay una razón muy
importante si ustedes van a ser un
negocio tienen que ser saber cómo lo van
a hacer es una realidad que van a hacer
que deseas qué sueñan cómo lo vas a
hacer pues pos con chino de ganas con
con mucha ímpetu con mucho orden el
orden en hacer en el hacer todos los
procesos que nosotros llevemos nos va a
dar muchísimo éxito esa es una parte
también importante que debemos de tener
en los negocios no sean leales sean sean
personas honestas sean personas que
trabajen bien den su palabra el día a
día en las cosas de los negocios yo creo
que ya se perdió esa ya se perdió
esa parte cuando tú das tu palabra de
hacer una cosa son son culturas que
gracias a mis padres he aprendido en los
ranchos no hay contratos en los ranchos
la gente no conoce vamos a un notario a
que te firme el proyecto del contrato
los ranchos de la palabra que tú das es
lo que vas a hacer ese es un valor que
se está perdiendo hoy en día con la
juventud yo los invito a que a que sean
sean parte de ese rezago de personas que
todavía quedan a que volvamos ya que
impulsemos las costumbres de antes
porque digo esto porque hoy en día si
vas a emprender la gente que trabajaban
en en aquellos años en el rancho era
gente que se levantaba muy temprano era
gente que trabajaba duro nosotros
queremos emprender pero te quieres
levantar a las 9 de la mañana es una
realidad tú qué estás haciendo tu
negocio y quieres que estar ahí tu
casita gusto
y eso no pasa nada no el emprender es
levantarte temprano idea trabaja hasta
tarde
frijoles no duermas muchas cosas que
realmente les digo de las personas que
seguía yo agarraba un poquito eso y es
una realidad dicen hoy espero porque vas
a emprender puedes levantarme a la hora
que me miran post y caro pero el dinero
está temprano el dinero todo lo que sean
los proyectos atiendes temprano haces
las cosas temprano
repito discúlpenme si de pronto repito
muchas cosas esto no para mí me
encantaría expresarme como como soy
realmente
pero bueno batalló un poco y lo que
quiero hacer es apoyar un poco a la
gente que la gente sepa que se pueden
lograr sus sueños que se pueden hacer
los negocios tan grandes tan pequeños
como lo crean pero para mí una clara
imagen está en demostrar que que así
empezamos y decir cuando la gente va ahí
y me dice luciano chino cabrón que
bonita tu empresa como el cómo has
logrado eso y la realidad es que
se logra por
por el hambre que la vida me dio por la
carencia en mi vida
la carencia fue algo que marcó que soy
agradecido porque tengo una familia
maravillosa que me acompaña una familia
que me apoya tengo una esposa que nunca
me ha dejado tengo unos hijos que son mi
impulso día a día y sobre todo tengo a
un gran maestro que que siempre está del
lado mío es importante que siempre
busquen un mentor esa es una realidad si
es válido si es algo que te suma la
experiencia de la vida de las personas
es lo más importante que te puede
generar lo más importante que te puede
sumar a tu vida
acá es muy pocas veces pero cuando cai
sabes que tienes alguien que te ayuda
que tienes alguien que te inspira que
tienes a alguien que comprende tus
errores que te va a decir que bien que
está mal y al final tú tomas la decisión
tu toma la última decisión de decir por
aquí me voy por acá no pero también esos
errores te hacen crecer los errores
realmente te hacen decir
pues yo quería irme por este camino pero
pues bueno ya me dijeron que no y al
final del día te das cuenta que la vida
de un emprendedor es puros errores / más
errores cometas más profesional te
vuelves es para mí es algo ilógico no
pero pero si ustedes
supieran la cantidad de errores en la
vida que he cometido y realmente no me
no me
no me no me arrepiento de haber cometido
tantos errores que son los que hoy en
día gracias a dios'
tengo una empresa que yo siempre soñé en
mi empresa es una empresa que hoy en día
se llama grupo amase y de ese grupo se
emanan otras dos empresas y se estuve en
qué momento en qué momento puedes tú
lograr eso pues en el que el emprendedor
que no no tiene ideas o no sueña pues no
vas a llegar a nada no vas a hacer tu
empresa chiquitas y hasta llegaste
muchas personas me dicen hoy es es que
pues ya puse mi empresita y no quieren
soltar el negocio y como crees q y con
un lecho ganas pues sí si tienes temor a
contratar más gente si tienes temor a
que te van a robar si tienes temor a que
a que no vas a crecer tu empresa va a
ser tan grande como tú las sueñes tu
empresa va a ser tan enorme como tú la
imagines
y pues bueno quiero agradecerles el
tiempo ojalá y me den la oportunidad de
algún día de volver a platicar con más
con más preparación me encantaría
expresarme de una manera más profesional
y les agradezco mucho el tiempo que me
escucharon y bueno soy luciano reyna
garcía un orgulloso emprendedor
regiomontana muchas gracias
[Aplausos]